bella tutti ragazzi ma volevo fare una
intro un po particolare però siccome per
una volta non sono nella mia camera e
sono qui in un parco a vivere la vita
reale è prendermi l'allergia
volevo fare un altro bel ragazzi allora
siccome io di solito faccio vedere che
ho sempre i giochi più figli tipo sui
piigs
questa volta siamo all'aperto perché il
gioco di oggi è un po più adatto
all'aperto
stiamo parlando di questo che è il pin
dalu e non sapere che cosa vi faccio
vedere praticamente abbiamo un altro
abbiamo un tubo a forma di u 2 palline
che vanno inseriti all'interno del tubo
e tu puoi fare cose [ __ ] che io so fare
perché io sono un professionista di
giochi però giocare all'aperto è sempre
meglio farlo con gli amici
quindi oggi ha portato negli amici amici
che bello avere degli amici faremo le le
sfide con il pin da lui i due perdenti
pagheranno la penitenza però prima non
sento ci dobbiamo riscaldare e poi
respinta lobont android
no no così tv rischia dai premi in pien
da lui fin dal mazzo allora allora
[Musica]
[Applauso]
direi che possiamo passare alla parte
delle sfide questa è la prima consiste
nel prendere la palla al volo abbiamo
solo tre tentativi a testa però perché
lezione perché avevano degli amici
normali che problemi hanno o no questo
secondo me era un altra roba tu devi
lanciare la pallina in aria riprenderla
l'ho fatto trovata bene dove non vale do
vale do basta
ecco mai to bike bike anche se lo vuoi e
bay per forza
tanti auguri
io quando mi trattano questa cosa mi dà
fastidio mi doveva sbagliare io non ho
bisogno di tipo non vi preoccupate per
io non lo faccio
fai da te senti una cosa e pietro poi
qualcosa è un ragazzo leale ci pensa o
un cigno è riuscito no dai
quindi la testa non è comunque siccome
il pin da lui nasce con due palline
quindi così in teoria gli esperti di
questo gioco
partono con due palline non con una
vastissima scalmo lato mare la forza di
coriolis liberatorio qui tentativo
numero due è venuta bene per la terza
abbiamo un modo di invitarti veramente
originale prego
[Musica]
[Applauso]
torniamo una pallina questa delle
palline da parte facciamo perché meglio
troppo bravo se passiamo alla prossima
adesso siccome la prima non me l'hai con
tata
gli avevo fatto strike incredibili
adesso bisogna fargli fare tre giri di
fila come avevo fatto io prima
ok inizio sempre io sono bello dai no no
di amici appunto l'ho preso passiamo la
palla pietro è mai neanche uno
[Musica]
vai appunto è persa la già bene mi sento
di pietro ultimo l'ultima parte della
sfida da fa lorenzo da complemento fra
con che schifo anche il cairo 23 anni
infatti 33 papa un punto un punto va
bene
no dei punti a 101 no adesso
finora abbiamo scherzato re e fermo
quando parlo adesso facciamo una roma po
più complicata
mi sono inventata una sfida a coppie
mettiamola così la faccio prima io con
lorenzo poi io con pietro voi non lo
fate perché io bene di avere una
possibilità in meno perché io sono sul
mio canale non faccio le visite sono
amico base 5
non vedo niente proviamo così a adesso
sì
no 93 94 lanciata stortissima lei perché
non ci credo voi fatto a prendere play
[Musica]
quindi punto è fatta carico va bene 12
lei non vale però ma prendi ma questi 12
ma tirato in così grande evidenza per te
devi da theo chi lo fa per i miei fan
vogliono che vinca c'è però dobbiamo
lavorare lì dove vanno la piscina ma che
spettacolo faccia se penitenza è va dai
ragazzi qui dentro ci sono le penitenze
che dobbiamo fare
la prima chi va vabbè la prima me dai
vari da jean louis walsh wright pilot
darà rara indossare eventi magliette
bagnate fradici 22 preso guarda che
gioco di magia pietro a te l'onore ma si
può grazie mille 321 fashion veron ora
gara il problema fa caldo ma nascono
così mi rimangono attaccate al corpo le
braccia fa niente poi mia madre invece
poiché sia sociale perché è per questo
motivo perché se conosco persone mi
fanno queste cose
sento hannibal lecter poi ti mangio il
cervello e trova lo so che da voi che
sto facendo anche se non potete fai
vedere i suoi scritti come soffre eh sì
che si facendo però rimette la vita vi
sono slogato un polmone
secondo me non sono abbastanza voglia di
queste magliette vero l'oro impari a
perdere
ciao ciao nel caso volesse far due tiri
ci sta ci sta
che bello avere degli amici amici mai e
dietro ori beckham è orribile
va bene vittima beve centrifugato di
cibo messicano
eccomi ok a 22
vuoi una sono due litri 9 possiamo anche
vedere umano ma dove aspetta via
cappello la forza è quello dei messicani
si trova visto che è mi sembra giusto il
gargari e eva così forte è forte
chissà che vai zio
dai che cosi finito manda giu almeno
questo mandi giù
sei un eroe lorenzo applaude gravissimo
[Applauso]
[Risate]
possiamo fare ma comunque ragazzi la
sfida di oggi finisce qua ci siamo
divertiti un sacco un saggio precettore
una base nelle magliette e stato
divertente e ricordo tutti quanti non
fatelo a casa perché noi siamo dei
professionisti quindi ragazzi spero che
vi sia piaciuto per informazioni sul pin
da lui vi lascio lì in descrizione e io
ci vorrei essere alla vostra altezza è
però vabbè prof
no no no quella era un'altra era
un'altra sfida non l'ho però questa mi
incuriosisce no fry un'altra sfida
questo non possiamo usarla perché no no
ma se ma è pazzo ma perché devi anche
soffrire sono caramelle che frizzano
quando le metti in bocca era un'altra
delle penitenze che però lui fa come se
non fate niente votanti ma da piccolo
faceva solo questo e si vede ragazzi io
vorrei qui il video
spero che video vi sia piaciuto se hai
resistito e noi ci vediamo a non posso
non posso tenere telecomando però ci
vediamo non possiamo video larghezza